so you're the third best host like how
much grinding did you need to do how
much grinding on the on the ladder did
you need to do man [ __ ] off i guess i
guess i guess like what is what
constitutes as grinding in the host see
that's a good thing so i guess i can go
into like the um downsides of being a
host at this point yeah okay um
tying it back down to why people even go
to the host club so the reason is
because you can only find a hostel in
the host club
right why because the guy is working in
the evening until morning sometimes he
sleeps he wakes up he does his daily
course chores and then he has to go to
work again and it's like 5 p.m yeah so
that's why the only time you can see a
hostel is you know at the club
but as like a you know successful hostel
who has a bunch of clients that they're
juggling you have to go to lunches you
have to go to their birthdays you have
to go to anniversaries or whatever the
sorts to disneyland and you have to
spend a lot of money on gifts right when
you go on a date with them exactly this
is something you pay for everything
right
yeah during the day when you see them i
mean i don't do that because i never
went on a date with a girl during the
day
because i just didn't care all right but
number one guy
that's the difference between me and the
number one guy because that's what he
did right he would sleep like two hours
and then he would go on a date with a
girl to disneyland act like he's having
fun buy [ __ ] at the disney store
you know it's literally like school it's
like if you do extracurricular
activities you're going to be like place
time yeah but you have to same thing
because it's like a give and take right
yeah the more you invest in the girls
that you hang out with the more they
want to give back but you know that's
not what i was interested in i always
made my interest very clear from the
beginning which is
why the [ __ ] are you here i'm just gonna
collect data first this literally just
sounds like persona 5.
you like bring a gift like the social
rank increases sometimes
does your mind just like connect
everything with the yeah
[Music]
yeah it is it's like you go on a date if
you want the girl to fight alongside you
during the battle then you gotta be nice
to them in the real world right this is
just the exact same thing this is a
simulation persona 5 is a host simulator
discovery of the same discovery of the
century
god damn
okay yeah cause like oh my god because
like yeah when you said gift like giving
gifts and stuff like that and the host
has to give gifts i can't imagine how
many gifts you have to give considering
japan's gift giving culture is already
insane it's bash it crazy bro the number
one hostel he would tell me depending on
the month
you point out how the stars online and
how many people have you know
anniversaries and [ __ ]
yeah he might spend up to 70 of his
income
on just gifting [ __ ]
going to places doing [ __ ] right right
you know but i guess that's like an
investment for him for sorts right yeah
i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then when your
birthday comes and then you're calling
like 14 girls to your birthday and
they're all paying like
you know
300.
[Applause]
i saw like advertisements of like one
host that he'd made over a hundred
thousand dollars in one night from his
birthday easy bro
hundred thousand dollars from from gifts
or just from people coming you know
gifts right
champagne tower that they built for you
that's when you like you that that's an
actual person who wishes their birthday
was two days
the one guy who's like can i have a
birthday month please
like i'll be great i've got 24 hours in
my birthday like i guess i'm all
sleeping tonight because that's like an
extra like [ __ ] 10k that i could be
earning yeah yeah
what i'll get
one thing i remember
definitely being a um definite downside
i'd say is that a lot of them you know a
lot of them seemed like they had
uh
developed uh an alcohol addiction of
sorts
because you're forced to drink
almost every day
all right through a lot a lot yeah yeah
can we go over the the whole drinking
culture for sure
let's do it yeah it seems interesting
okay
he literally finished a quarter of his
gym
okay so i one thing that i found really
weird is that they were all just talking
to each other and joking about how they
had all been like throwing up that
morning because it was like
right right and i was like how often do
you i don't i'm not sure if it's in the
video so how often do you like get so
drunk that you up he was like yeah three
four times a week
three four times a week that's just
throwing up from drinking that's insane
that's that's insane how much do you
have to drink on like a regular working
night
um
for me it was mostly just about how much
i i want yeah
so so are you allowed to so say if like
one of your clienteles like buys you a
drink
can you say no to exactly so did you
have the money the way the structure
within the host club works is if you're
the one coming in with a client already
that you met you sit at the table side
like us right and across from us you
would have a head and helping person who
would be the one arranging the drinks
pouring [ __ ] out of this you know the
peasantry workplace
stuff i haven't done in ages was he was
he a host himself or was it just yeah
they're they're all hostile they're all
hostile oh sorry but he was like they're
down in the ranks
if you don't have a girl for yourself
then might as well help your bro kind of
thing right right right and your
specific job is to just drink so that
your homie doesn't have to drink so he
can persuade the girl to buy more drinks
so that you can drink kind of thing
right so he literally gets paid to drink
your drinks yeah exactly
yeah because because you so i don't know
we've said this in the episode but like
the way that hosts make money is from
them buying drinks right yeah for sure
and food too bro so you get a cut of
every single drink or how does it work
at the end of the night depending on the
payment but
usually you get 40 of the spent spent
spending at the grocery spending so the
550 dollar drink you might get like yeah
if the girls spent a thousand why did
you choose 15 people 10 drinks you get
four dollars you get four dollars
why are you hiring her just hire like a
[ __ ] aussie in the back room just
likes
like does that aussie speak japanese
that's why at the beginning of the
episode i said he could be a great host
no no
going with how this story is gone i
wouldn't be a great host i'd be a great
host who helps his hobie finishes
so so this helper guy he will sit at the
table
while you you are while you're talking
and he'll drink your drink that this
girl has brought for you he doesn't talk
right no of course he told was you have
to make good conversation because i was
doing that for two years bro what you
have to do is just make conversation but
like how do you not step on the other
guy's toes if it's his girl yeah it's
his goal well sometimes some treacherous
[ __ ] happens
[Music]
mostly happened between me and the
number one guy of the place i worked at
because we're really close homies yeah
because number one guy was very
interesting man this guy he was a normal
salary man
in the architecture business earning a
you know good salary for world standard
until he was 27. and one day he said
[ __ ] this i'm just gonna become a host
literally like he just gave up
everything he said you know i don't care
about it anymore i'm just going to
become a host and he's [ __ ]
successful at it dude a genius he's very
smart very good looking feminine as [ __ ]
but that just
that's how it works that's just the way
it is but this guy for example what
we're talking about by the way
because obviously you have the helper
and the main guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
sure yeah so when this guy brings and
you know like there will be evenings
where number one guy would invite like
seven eight different girls at the same
time yeah so he like we went out and get
pissed off see they can't say anything
what are the girls going to say
the girls can say like um i'm buying you
drinks give me more attention what he
says well
sucks for you other girls want me too
but i don't want it get the [ __ ] out no
because then they would disable what
they would do is they'd be like hey uh
if you want your turn you gotta buy me
the champagne thing yeah exactly you
want to stay
shopping is right there we're gonna pop
it and i'll stand up it's literally like
some kind of like [ __ ] squid game ass
thing where like putting them against
each other yeah right yeah but in the
essence of it it's really kind of like a
it's taking an advantage kind of thing
of course it's absolutely taking it
but in the grand scheme of things the
girls are the ones who decide to come
come back to it
yeah that's true you're not i guess
they're not helping you you're not tying
them down right right right strange yeah
i don't know
in some ways it yeah that's one way to
look at it but i'm sure there's it's way
deeper than that right it's yeah i feel
like yeah i don't know it depends on the
person i guess right yeah
i mean it just feels like the host the
entire host culture and the entire host
world just works like obviously
different social rules and different
social values i mean yes i mean none of
them would probably be in a host club if
that wasn't the case right
we're four guys talking about why women
might go to it right we probably don't
understand it as well as we think we do
sure yeah so i feel like you know i
don't want to come off as a misogynistic
or anything like that
yeah i'm sure there's a lot more layers
to it that we don't understand i don't
understand the culture we're obviously
just talking from like a surface well i
i i honestly just find it's fascinating
yeah didn't say go over though like did
why why the demographic yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah right but i'm sure i'm sure
not all girls like that though right
like why they come back tonight yeah i'm
sure
there's a lot more to it yeah yeah you
know it's one of those things as well
and i don't know i feel like as well
because
i guess misogyny in japan is like a
thing
like a bit more than the west i'd
probably say i mean it's like i mean the
rules are structured around it right
like
well and the laws as well the
interesting thing about that is um
so in any culture whether japanese or
whatever no girls are attracted towards
what's you know perceived as an alpha
right right someone who seems to be
someone who's someone who seems to
dominate the environment someone seems
like they're on top of things so the way
the horse care i think so in general
yeah so in terms of the hostile industry
in itself it's made so that if it's a
girl that you know that you invited is
coming over everybody around you
including the chacho you know the owner
of the business will do everything in
their power to make you look like the
rock star of the business
right for the time being because they
understand that if they do that the
girls will be like oh my god you know
the guy i've chosen you know he [ __ ]
owns the place right right the little
owner of the [ __ ] bar is bending over
[ __ ] you know doing backflips just to
like please my homie so right right i
must have chosen the right guy it's all
an act it's just all well it's not
though the thing is at least the way
acted you know yeah well okay well your
act is your act comes from some kind of
basis of you as a person yeah exactly
i'm sure all the other hosts do that
right yeah like like like how much
how much of like the host have like a
genuine personality behind their
character and how much is just like
completely made up
that depends from person to person right
i'm sure you've seen both cases right
yeah of course of course some of them
will really try to play it up yeah
and it's just not them at all yeah not
at all yeah but sometimes i mean you
know like piggy boy that
that you you went on a date with you
know like that guy bro
it was it was really bizarre because i i
didn't quite come across on the video
but
because obviously
it was cut in like five minutes like the
whole part yeah but he had this one uh
girl in that video who we blowed out uh
who was like obsessed with him right but
like he like didn't give her the time of
day like he barely gave any attention to
her yeah that's what she likes bro yeah
she was so weird watching it it was like
he literally couldn't give a [ __ ] and
she was like i'm gonna marry him and
he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah and it was
so it was so strange wasn't it meline
like watching this uh this guy right
here right here
back up back your homie
like you get your man
like obsessed this girl was about the
main host and he just like didn't give a
[ __ ] yeah and it was like
she bought she spent she bought me the
champagne because he was like oh i want
to i want to impress yeah just guys yeah
so she god knows how much she spent on
that champagne because the cheapest one
i saw was like 5k something dollars i
think yeah dollars well fun from like so
i don't want to know how much he spent
just to impress him for like one second
it didn't even seem like he gave a [ __ ]
right